I have 30 employees whose job it is to
watch all the footage right now and find
the best moments and we've already
tested rudimentary AI That's better than
that anybody need Dustin you know you
know what I mean it's not like oh now
you're fine like it'll just make them do
different things in 1860 80 of the world
worked on a farm and we meant the
tractors and we didn't have to do that
anymore we did different everyone's
demonizing ai ai is going to commoditize
certain things and if you are a Adobe
Photoshop designer that doesn't have a
thought to their brain and you make
everything that someone else tells you
you might be in trouble but if you are a
Adobe Photoshop designer that thinks
their ass off as they make their stuff
that's not being replaced tomorrow I'm
gonna call my AI bot Dustin